we move on to the New York Winter Garden Theatre
where the brightest stars of Broadway are paying
honor to the Schubert's in commemoration of the
theaters 25th anniversary the first speaker is
the radio and stage star Phil Baker I want you
ladies and gentlemen the laymen out front the
men and women who have nothing to do with the
theater to know that it took the Schubert's and
their courage to make what little the other
we have left survived among the many stars
who have come to pay tribute to the Schubert's
are Willy and Eugene Howard radio favorites who
appeared on this very stage 25 years ago
first law a famous comedian takes a bow
having been introduced by the well-known
master of ceremonies jack-offs tonight
here's Frank pay another present-day star who
appeared in this theater early in his career
the audience is treated to a funny story by
that master dialectician and storyteller Lou
Holtz and they were giving that in history
50 Lodge there a meeting on the Lower East
Side every fourth week and again way of pride
to the most stubborn man in the lodge so he
says gentlemen he says nobody is covering
as I'm attacking Ferguson's boy he said I
had a toothache I went to the dentist Texas
Dennis expect me to - teasing which Turner's
waiting on our answer I call my brother's to
think you've got the education of my model
fool me on everything except the right
one that six years is going to kill me
when abroad ways youngest and
best comedians Milton Berle
the nearest I ever got to the winner got was
the Roxy but I'll tell you the truth my aunt
I'm at the friend's honesty and paradise
freshmen over here it's marvelous residents
very beautiful three waiters teach Table one
gives you the check the other two revive you
but I feel Marla's cooking I was just hanging
outside the wall goes there that's where I
live outside the law office joining me I was
down a flower I drove around in one of those
Christ list streamlines you nor Thoreau
I took my mother Saturn the rumble seat
everybody makes mistakes I drove up to the
gas station to guess that it made a mistake
with 20 gallons gasoline around eight and thirty
pounds air and my mother too bad she only hold 20